In a recent gum-chewing
contest, Violet
tried to blow the biggest
blueberry-flavored bubble ever.
Every 3 seconds, she
added 1 piece of gum
to her huge bubble.
On the graph below, the x-axis
represents time in seconds.
So this right over
here is our x-axis.
And the y-axis represents pieces
of gum in Violet's bubble.
So this is the y-axis
right over here.
Plot points to show
how many pieces of gum
were in Violet's bubble
after 3, 6, and 9 seconds.
So every 3 seconds, she
adds one piece of gum.
So let me throw
all of my-- so what
we care is about 3 seconds,
6 seconds, and 9 seconds.
So every 3 seconds, we know
that she adds one piece of gum.
This is 0 right over here.
We're not going to worry
about negative time.
So after 3 seconds, she would
have added one piece of gum
to her bubble.
Now, if 3 more seconds pass by,
she would have added 1 more,
and now she would have 2
pieces of gum in her bubble.
And then if 3 more seconds pass
by, now we're at 9 seconds,
she would have added
1 more piece of gum,
and now we're at 3
total pieces of gum.
And notice, the ratio
between the pieces of gum
and the time that has
passed has stayed constant,
because she's doing
it at a constant rate.
1 to 3 is the same
ratio as 2 to 6,
which is the same
ratio as 3 to 9.
So, let's check our answer.
Very good.